[Musik]
das letzte mal shoppen klamotten kaufen
das war noch im weihnachtsgeschäft das
letzte mal friseur
das war kurz nach nikolaus das letzte
mal im restaurant dahin die blätter noch
an den bäumen aus vorübergehend
geschlossen wird in diesem land immer
häufiger für immer dicht ihr locker und
frust für den gibt es hier bei bild
offene ohren
wir diskutieren jetzt mit landrat mit
bürgermeister mit ihnen unseren
zuschauern darüber wie es in diesem land
wirklich aussieht wie dieses land
wirklich tickt nach 105 tagen im
lockdown locker und frust der geht quer
durchs land und dem wollen wir erstmal
zuhören mit dem bürgermeister von
illingen in saarland armin könig ist das
mit dem landrat des landkreises
ludwigslust parchim das ist stefan
sternberg und mit frank henkel der
früher hier in der hauptstadt berlins
innensenator war und cdu-chefin allen
schönen guten abend herr könig sie haben
kurzfristig ein brandbrief ein frust
brief geschrieben an ihren
ministerpräsidenten tobias hans im
saarland und an cdu chef armin laschet
und haben geschrieben sie also eher hand
verlassen
sie sind gerade dabei uns zurück zu
lassen wenn nicht sogar zu verlieren
warum verlieren wir haben momentan die
situation dass ein teil der bevölkerung
nicht mehr versteht was gespielt wird es
gab regeln die festgelegt wurden ich
nenne als beispiel den incidents werk 50
und jeder der bisher im lock down war ob
dessen und die gastronomen darauf dass
die kultur ist ob es die vielen kleinen
geschäfte sind die müssen natürlich
planen und die sind davon ausgegangen
wir werden jetzt wenn die zahlen besser
werden lanken für das geschäft erste
kommt und dann stellen wir plötzlich
fest
die spielerische und werden geändert es
ist alles anders als wir bisher erwartet
haben und plötzlich haben leute keine
perspektiven herr henkel sie haben das
ganze ähnlich ausgedrückt haben bei
facebook nicht geschrieben die menschen
verstehen nicht mehr was gespielt wird
aber sie haben geschrieben verlängern
den locker und doch am besten gleich bis
zur bundestagswahl dann werden wir das
land schon schaffen geht es bei ihnen
nur noch mit zynismus im moment ja es
hat weniger was mit zynismus zu tun auch
wenn sie es so anhört und das hat mehr
zu tun damit dass ich wie viele menschen
die ich kenne einfach verärgert wenn ich
so gar verbittert sind ich kann mich
meinem vorredner ja zu großen teilen
anschließend ich habe in dem von mir
betreuten wahlkreis eine fülle von
gastronomen den steht buchstäblich das
wasser bis zum hals die haben zum teil
noch nicht einmal ihre november hilfe
bekommen und natürlich vertrauen die
menschen auch auf politik was die
politik aber macht und das ist das was
wir sehen und das führte dann auch zu
dem was ich geschrieben habe
das ist doch keiner kann der politik wie
eine hoffnung auf eine rückkehr zur
normalität gibt das ist eine politik die
dafür sorgt dass es große
kollateralschäden gibt dass es menschen
gibt die vor den trümmern ihrer
wirtschaftlichen existenz steht ich
kenne mittelständler nicht nur
gastronomen ich kenne messebau keine
schausteller die haben seit über einem
jahr im grunde kein geld verdient und
dann bin ich schon sauer dass wir nicht
einmal die zugesagten november bzw
dezember hilfen bekommen ich habe immer
gesagt das ist eine großzügige hilfe 75
prozent vom umsatz des jahres ist toll
aber es nützt nichts wenn es nicht
ankommt und dann kommt hinzu was der
vorgänger in der tat gesagt hat die
menschen verstehen immer weniger was was
diese beschlüsse die jetzt gefasst
wurden was sie eigentlich darstellen was
die bedeutung wir werden ja jetzt schon
wieder letzter satz im grunde darauf
vorbereitet dass der siebte märz nur
wieder irgendein datum sein wird werde
ich mir heute die bild -zeitung anschaue
und mir anschaue was der sächsische
ministerpräsident dort erst einmal gut
2000 die henkel können wir gucken der
sagt heute osterurlaub voraussichtlich
gestrichen also das wird in diesem jahr
leider nicht geben sagt er ganz klar der
ministerpräsident des landes sachsen
michael kretschmer herr sternberg
sie sind landrat in mecklenburg
vorpommern landrat von ludwigslust
parchim und sie haben geschrieben berlin
war noch nie so weit weg von den
menschen wie in diesen wochen warum
naja die 35 ist ja die neue 50 und wenn
man das so nach denen nach der mpk mit
dem ministerpräsidenten und der
bundeskanzlerin so mitbekommen hat dann
ist es so wie als kreis haben uns zum
als also am freitag dieser woche das
erste mal wieder unter die 50 gearbeitet
und wir haben das alle erwartet und
jetzt ist die 50 eigentlich in klammern
nichts mehr wert und das macht natürlich
was mit den menschen gerade was die
maßnahmen angeht die wir hier die
letzten vier wochen ganz massiv noch
einmal verschärft haben und mit aller
kraft unter die 50 zu kommen sie haben
alle drei jetzt einmal die stimmung aus
ihrem umfeld von ihrer basis geschildert
viele menschen ist unser eindruck haben
auch deswegen im moment ein bisschen
frust oder ein bisschen mehr frust weil
sie das gefühl haben dass doch einiges
schön geredet wird
das kann man sicherlich so sagen
schulauswahl pleite wirtschaft hat im
fall sagen dass im großen ganzen nichts
schief gelaufen im großen und ganzen
nichts schief gelaufen das motto der
korona krisenpolitik schönreden vor
allem nach dem desaster das die
impfkampagne in europa vielerorts an
fahrt aufgenommen hat es war richtig und
es ist richtig dass wir europäerinnen
und europäer den impfstoff gemeinsam
bestellt haben auch sie redet vieles
schön die eu gesundheitskommissarin
steller korea guedes bekannt als füße
hochkommissarin er in einem
zeitungsinterview sagte sie heute die
europäische strategie ist ein erfolg
ähnlich zuvor die kanzlerin
und wenn sie mich vor einem jahr als sie
die ersten fälle hatten gefragt hätten
wann haben wir einen impfstoff dann
hätte ich nicht darauf gewettet dass wir
das so schnell hinbekommen
und er sorgte diese woche für einen der
höhepunkte des schönredens deutschlands
wichtigster eu gesundheitspolitiker
peter liese
wir haben nicht genug impfstoff in
europa
wir haben nicht noch impfstoff in
deutschland und wenn wir uns das
anschauen die deutsche statistik wir
sind da auf einem abstiegsplatz sind sie
gescheitert mit ihrer politik also da
würde ich jetzt wirklich mal an ihrer
stelle den mund nicht so voll nehmen
wenn sie wein abstiegsplatz reden auf
den abstiegsplätzen stehen japan wir
können jetzt erstrahlen jetzt gleich
noch einmal die statistik sondern gerne
in der sendung wo wieder da musst du
halt platz stehen zeigen sie bitte mal
japan steht jetzt nicht mit anderen
anfang haben sie sich auch alle schön
reden beim impfen schönreden auch bei
den drastischen folgen das lockt uns für
unsere wirtschaft jetzt können auch sehr
zufrieden sein ich möchte den
bürgerinnen und bürgern danken und
schönreden auch bei den drastischen
folgen das lockt bei uns für unsere
kinder
wir wissen dass bildung priorität hat
das haben wir alle immer wieder gesagt
105 tage lockdown 105 tage frust und
unsere regierung setzt immer noch auf
schönreden
ich glaube dass im großen ganzen nichts
schiefgelaufen ist und diese äußerung
der kanzlerin bezog sich explizit auf
die eu impfdosen bestellung der henkel
wenn sie solche stimmen moment gebannt
hören was denken sie
wenn sie so was hören solche ja
weitestgehend zufriedene stimmen
beruhigende stimmen
erstmalig april gesagt das macht zum
großen teil auch nicht nur zügig das
macht auch bitter wenn man dann selbst
als politiker das gefühl hat man sogar
nicht mehr abgeholt wenn das gefühl
bekommt die menschen werden nicht mehr
abgeholt sondern man ist ausgeliefert
und man so hat man das gefühl zum teil
für dumm verkauft dann ist das ein ganz
ganz ans bitteres gefühl die kanzlerin
hat vor ein paar tagen gesagt
uns ist das ding endlich um später dann
zu sagen alles in allem ist nicht so
viel schief gelaufen
beides kann ja nicht stimmen sternberg
trifft die regierung im moment den ton
nicht
ja definitiv nicht also mann hatte man
das gefühl die kommen da zusammen lassen
sich wieder eine neue drastische
maßnahme für die ganze bundesrepublik
einfallen und es wird gar nicht auch
regional geguckt und ich glaube dass wir
diese ja dieser virus wird nicht im
mehrzwecksaal der wird doch nicht mal
april weg sein er wird bis juni/juli da
sein und wir können ja mit der
salamitaktik jetzt noch weiter schreiben
von der wurst deutschland abschneiden
aber nun wird bald nichts mehr übrig
bleiben und sie trifft den ton ganz und
gar nicht und wir verlieren wirklich
immer mehr bürger und das sehen wir ja
vor ort weil wir am ende mit die unseren
allgemeinverfügung und so das auch
umsetzen müssen und mir perfekt ist
selber manchmal schon wirklich schwer
das noch zu erklären was ist es was
ihnen konkret fehlte könig weil die
regierung heute beispielsweise
kretzschmar sagt ja na ja am ende
entscheidet das virus über die strategie
über die länge des lok downs nicht die
politik was fehlt ihnen im moment
konkrete perspektive noch hoffnung
also ich halte das was kretschmann sagt
für völligen unsinn
tatsache ist dass wir einen zeitplan
brauchen was wir waren wollen das ist in
der wirtschaft es ist auch in vielen
anderen gesellschaftlichen bereichen das
ist ein sport selbstverständlich dass
man zeitpläne dass man perspektiv pläne
macht dass man sagt wenn ein szenario
mache ich so passt das nicht mache einen
alternativplan das wird als erste
erarbeitet man hat im sommer alles total
verschlafen hätte damals schon
strategisch vorgehen müssen und es gibt
überhaupt keine strategie habe ich
inzwischen den eindruck sondern man
fährt immer weiter auf sich das kann so
nicht funktionieren wir brauchen klare
lösungen
ich sehe momentan so eine art kipp punkt
gekommen das heißt also wenn das jetzt
in eine andere richtung gibt wird es
sehr schwierig die bevölkerung
mitzunehmen und die brauchen wir
dringend danke ihnen drei für diese
stimmungsbild ganz aus dem südwesten der
republik aus dem nordosten und auch hier
aus dem bezirk nur aus berlin danke
frank henkel stefan sternberg und armin
könig dafür dass sie uns dieses
stimmungsbild vermittelt haben und bei
uns im studio bei bildes jetzt peter
tschentscher erster bürgermeister
hamburgs und einer der die bei den video
konferenzen bei den wichtigen
entscheidungen dort mit am tisch sitzen
bzw zugeschaltet sind schönen guten
abend gute nacht wenn sie diesen frust
das ist natürlich ein ausschnitt aus der
republik aber warum haben sie es
zugelassen dass all dieser frust
überhaupt herrscht im moment in der in
deutschland die stimmung schlecht ich
glaube das kann man insgesamt sagen es
sind aber unterschiedliche punkte die
eben jetzt auch mit zum teil drastischen
worten ja angesprochen worden der erste
punkt ist und da muss man nichts
schönreden die impfstoff beschaffung in
der eu ist natürlich schief gelaufen ist
wurde zu spät bestellt ist wurde gerade
jetzt für den beginn zu wenig bestellt
und deswegen dauert das jetzt so lange
bis hier ausreichend impfschutz betreute
wenn ich ganz kurz ein haken darf die
zuständige eu gesundheitskommissar kitas
im amt bleiben und das ja ich sage jetzt
erst einmal wir haben als das spd ja
sehr früh anfang des jahres schon in
frage gestellt ob das alles so
vernünftig entschieden worden ist und
das hat sich jetzt herausgestellt das
war wirklich zu spät bestellt wurde zu
wenig und dass wir in deutschland jetzt
im internationalen vergleich so
hinterherhinken ist natürlich auch eine
folge dieser falschen beschaffung auf
europäischer ebene
der zweite punkt ist keine kleine sache
dass man gemeinsam entscheiden
wir müssen ja vertrauen dass die
zuständige gesundheitskommissarin die
absolut richtige ist das hier
aufzuräumen
nach einem solchen desaster gehen sie
davon aus dass sie das kann dass sie in
diesem abend die richtige wenn jetzt
nicht derjenige der beurteilen kann ob
es wirklich eine einzelne person ist die
dafür zuständig war und jetzt
zurücktreten musste ich meine
deutschland hatte die eu
ratspräsidentschaft wir haben eine
deutsche kommissionspräsidentin ich weiß
nicht ob das jetzt für uns gerade die
richtige rolle ist zu sagen da hat eine
einzelne der kommissarin aus einem
anderen land die alleinige verantwortung
ist seit verantwortlich sie leiterin
corinna task force ja es ist richtig
also ich bin aber jetzt als deutscher
ministerpräsident und erster
bürgermeister einer stadt nicht
derjenige der entscheiden kann wie auf
europäischer ebene jetzt die
konsequenzen zu ziehen sind aus dieser
das muss von der leyen lauf und das
müssen diejenigen tun die dort in
europäischen politik eine rolle haben
das könnte auch gerne die
europaabgeordneten mal kritisch
aufarbeiten
aber das ist jetzt ein ganz wesentlicher
punkt der mir auch frost macht ich meine
wir haben in zentren aufgebaut in den
ländern und könnten das vierfache jetzt
dann im verfolgt haben sie die
verantwortung deswegen noch einmal
nachgefragt dafür für das eu imf
desaster muss frau von der leyen die
verantwortung übernehmen und im zweifel
eben jetzt erklären was die konsequenzen
sind noch einmal das ist auf der
europäischen ebene zu klären
von der leyen ist eu
kommissionspräsident in die deutsche
bundesregierung hat die bundesrats
präsidentschaft im letzten halben jahr
gehabt
und natürlich muss eine zwischen die
kommissarin auch rede und antwort stehen
wenn hoffentlich europaabgeordnete diese
dinge noch einmal aufklären was mir
nicht gefällt es dann dass man noch
lange gesagt hat das hätte man nicht
anders machen können ohne ihren weißen
siedler ist wieder einmal stellen weise
eingeräumt worden dass man durchaus auch
anders hätte vorgehen können und
insbesondere hätte man glaube ich früh
darauf achten müssen dass wir in dem
moment wo impfstoffe erfolgreich
getestet sind noch ausreichend impfstoff
produktionskapazitäten zur verfügung das
ist das eine der imster das ist aber
sagt mehr punkte die es war ja vor allen
dingen an der frust bedeutet und der
auch gerade in diesen drei beiträgen
dadurch gekommen ist ist dass die dass
viele unternehmen wirklich sehr kritisch
jetzt belastet sind vielleicht kurz vor
der insolvenz stehen und das ist deshalb
enorm wichtig ist dass die zugesagten
hilfen jetzt endlich ausgezahlt werden
das ist für die november und dezember
hilfe jetzt so weit dass das möglich ist
nach meiner information sind die
abschlagszahlung auch weitestgehend
erfolgt wir gehen jetzt in die
endgültige ja es ist hat so lange
gedauert aber es ist natürlich auch so
ich habe gerade heute gehört wie viel
missbrauch mit anträgen bei diesen
wirtschaftshilfen wie viel missbrauch
dort wird würde man im nachhinein
wahrscheinlich sagen lieber einmal zu
viel gezahlt als dann am ende tausende
warten lassen das ist natürlich das
siebte abschlagszahlung also ich kann
jetzt für hamburg sprechen wir haben 95
prozent der november und dezember hilfen
abschlagszahlung erteilt und sind jetzt
in der endgültigen bewilligung und die
helfen den gerade den restauration
betrieben sehr weil das ja eine recht
großzügige umsatz das ist das zweite das
lange warten auf die wirtschaft sind
jetzt mal einen entscheiden haben dass
die leute hier und jetzt kommt das
dritte wo ich nicht ganz die meinung
teile die dort vorgetragen wurde dass
die politik jetzt die spielregeln
geändert hat sondern das virus hat die
spielregeln geändert wir nennen das
mutation und da sagen uns
wissenschaftler dass das große
auswirkungen haben kann die dann anders
sozusagen die pandemie sich sich
darstellen lassen als sie das bisher im
letzten jahr gewohnt sind wir haben ja
diese grenze von 50 die auch nie
wissenschaftlich hergeleitet wurde das
sind auch willkürlich aus der überlegung
auf die gesundheitsämter wann können die
nun man wer bei welchem
infektionsgeschehen können wir davon
ausgehen dass wir die sache noch unter
kontrolle behalten können
und dieser wert von 50 war so die grenze
wo wir gesagt haben da sind wir nicht
mehr im risikobereich daher wird es
gehen
nun haben wir aber diese unsicherheit
der mutation und die kann dazu führen
dass die infektiosität der viren auch in
deutschland sowie in großbritannien
sowie in portugal plötzlich sehr viel
höher wird und dann ist es eben
schwieriger die infektion zu
kontrollieren und deswegen nicht weil
die politik gesagt das wollen wir mal
frust verbreiten und spielregeln ändern
sondern aus vorsichtsgründen haben wir
gesagt wir müssen jetzt aufgrund dieses
unsicherheitsfaktor nochmal einen
sicherheits das heißt nicht sie regieren
mehr nicht
dass die kanzlerin nicht die
ministerpräsidenten regieren sondern das
virus regiert uns nein wir können dass
das dem virus ist das recht wenn wir
unsere lockerungen nicht vornehmen oder
vornehmen dem virus ist es sogar sehr
recht sich so auszubreiten wie es in
großbeeren grunde nur heute argumentiert
er sagt nur die verantwortung liegt am
ende beim virus
nein wir haben eine verantwortung dafür
dass wir gut durch die pandemie kommen
das ist in deutschland wenn sie das mal
in den todeszahlen vergleichen mit
frankreich mit spanien mit portugal
vielleicht nicht optimal gelungen
jedenfalls besser als in den
europäischen nachbarländern
sie hören ja und sehen ja was in
großbritannien los ist wie die
wirtschaft noch viel härter getroffen
ist weil ein dortiger regierungschef das
einfach auf die leichte schulter
genommen hat und wir versuchen jetzt in
deutschland mit ein bisschen unterschied
in dem in den schwerpunkten diese dritte
welle zu vermeiden die ja eintreten
würde wenn wir jetzt zu verstehen ist in
die in die lockerungen gehe stetig und
der frust und der schaden der dann
ausgelöst wird der ist ammann vielfach
ist noch größer als das was wir derzeit
schon haben können sie heute wenn wir so
sehr vom virus bestimmt werden können
sie heute versprechen gehen sie davon
aus dass es dieses jahr überhaupt noch
normales leben geben wird dass wir
normal reisen werden dass wir in leeden
reingehen werden ohne dass wir ständig
masken tragen müssen aufeinander
abstand halten müssen usw dass wir
wieder normal miteinander leben also
versprechen kann wer das alle nicht weil
weil in so einer pandemie gibt es immer
wieder neue unsicherheitsfaktoren aber
die wahrscheinlichkeit ist dass wir
mitte des jahres und vor allem dann im
september wenn möglichst alle eine
impfung schon erhalten konnten
dass wir dann sehr viel stabiler da
schien ich glaube die wahrscheinlichkeit
ist sehr hoch
nur momentan sind wir noch auf sehr
dünnem als wir haben noch zu wenig
geimpft es ist noch sehr sehr kalt diese
kalten temperaturen helfen dem virus und
machen es uns schwerer shoppen ohne
maske zum beispiel ja momentan würde ich
das auch nicht ein warum dieses jahr
noch machen kann mir vorstellen dass ich
auch sagen dass wir im sommer sehr viel
besser dastehen wenn es dann wirklich
nur noch die masken sind die wir tragen
müssen beim shoppen werden wir ja eine
riesen schritt war er aber da gehen
trotzdem kein normales leben also ein
teilweiser wäre ja sagen würde dass
halter ertragen aber dann sagen die
masken pflicht beim öffentlichen
nahverkehr und beim einkaufen ist jetzt
etwas woran man sich vielleicht auch
noch ein paar monate länger daran
gewöhnen könnte viel wichtiger ist ja
dass die kultur wieder beginnen kann
dass wir wieder sport machen das wie
clara würde bedeuten am ende locker und
regeln zumindest einige was die kontakte
kontakte angeht möglicherweise das ganze
jahr über
ich kann mir vorstellen dass wir einige
dieser dieser beschränkung noch eine
weile behalten müssen aber das hängt
eben sehr stark davon ab wie wir jetzt
mit der impfung mit der impfung
vorankommen und jetzt muss ich leider
wieder sagen wie das virus mit spielt
natürlich gibt es jetzt schon erste
berichte dass das virus mutationen gibt
gegen die die impfstoffe nicht ganz so
wirksam sind
das muss man dann das ist jetzt auch
keinen keine riesenunglück man kann
diese impfstoffe anpassen und das ist
momentan auch nicht klar ob die die
impfung dann doch die erkrankung
verhindert was ja wichtig ist also noch
zu viele unsicherheitsfaktoren in einer
sehr komplexen pandemie lage als dass
irgendjemand jetzt garantien für termine
oder maßnahmen geben kann
wir diskutieren jetzt mit hamburgs
erster bürgermeister peter tschentscher
und außerdem mit dieser runde nämlich
mit wolfgang kubicki fdp und
bundestags-vizepräsident mit tübingens
oberbürgermeister boris palmer mit jana
schimke der cdu mittelstands vize und
mit peter ramsauer dem langjährigen
verkehrsminister aus der csu in allen
schönen guten abend herr kubicki wir
haben gerade viel über die stimmung im
land gehört herrn chen chow nun auch
dazugehört nehmen sie auch ein
vertrauensverlust im moment war
gegenüber der kompletten politik das
trifft sie alle nationalität sogar weil
für das versagen der bundesregierung
nicht die bundesregierung selbst
verantwortlich gemacht wird sondern die
gesamte politik ihr politiker wieder
kriegt das nicht auf die kette das
betrifft ja nicht nur den kampf gegen
das virus in form von fi 2 mass nämlich
ausreichend da sind oder schnelltest die
nicht ausreichen da sind vor allen
dingen das impfchaos das peinlichkeit
kaum zu überbieten ist das betrifft auch
die menschen die jeden tag existenz
bringen müssen
ich bin gerade formalen steuerberaten im
büro waren darauf hingewiesen worden
dass derlei die überbrückungshilfe drei
mittlerweile von der steuerberater kann
man mit 40 seiten versehen worden ist
welche dinge man beachten muss bei der
beantragung rein oder raus gestolpert
das sind verzweifelte jetzt machen
sollen die menschen sind verzweifelt bei
denen nichts ankommt ich höre dass die
bewegungs ihre drei wenn überhaupt wenn
sie jetzt beantragt werden kann
frühestens ende märz ausgezahlt wird das
halten viele alter nicht mehr durch und
wenn wir feststellen dass auch im
november hefel noch nicht vollständig
ausgezahlt ist die djembé ist mitte
februar
worauf sollen die menschen dann noch
dazu kommen auch gleich herr kubicki
herr palmer wir haben gerade gehört dass
vor allen dingen die sache locker und
frust ja zu tief sitzt und es wurde
damit begründet dass man gesagt menschen
gucken die ganze zeit auf diesen wert 50
und jetzt wo wir ganz knapp an der 50
sind heißt es plötzlich 35 das machen
wir nicht mehr mit kennen sie das
ja das kam ja doch jetzt ja überraschend
diese wendung die begründung mit der
mutation kann man annehmen
aber da die 50 schon nicht gut begründet
war ist die 35 jetzt auch nicht sehr
einsichtig denn mit der fähigkeit der
gesundheitsämter zur kontrolle der
pandemie hat ist einfach nichts zu tun
das hängt gar nicht mehr von den
fallzahlen ab sondern von den prozessen
die sind zu langsam
weil wir das alles händisch machen und
versuchen das gedächtnis der leute zu
erforschen
wenn die da freundschaften nicht
riskieren wollen sagen sie nicht mehr wo
sie gewesen sind unser problem ist dass
wir einfach nicht herausfinden wo die
infektion stattgefunden hat das könnte
man ändern mit moderner technik tun wir
aber nicht und so weit ist es klar dass
wir über die gesundheitsämter diese
pandemie nicht unter kontrolle bringen
werden also flüchtet man sich zu
instituts werden und hofft dass die
richtig gewählt sind aber keiner weiß wo
der richtige liegt schimke sie haben
diese woche in der unions
bundestagsfraktion für aufsehen gesorgt
quasi mit einem hilferuf von der basis
haben gesagt ich weiß ja gar nicht mehr
was ich in meinem wahlkreis überhaupt
noch erzählen soll
was erzählen sie denn aber ihren
menschen im wahlkreis wissen sie das
kerngeschäft eines politikers gerade in
corona zeiten besteht darin erst einmal
zu erklären warum die bundesregierung
dieses und jenes beschließt und wir
die dinge so machen wie wir sie machen
und zweitens vor allen dingen hoffnungen
zu geben ja das ist dass wir bald licht
am ende des tunnels haben dass wir bald
wieder öffnen können dass wir bald
wieder in ein normales leben
zurückführen können aber inzwischen muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen gehen wir da auch
die worte aus weil ich sehe wie die
existenzen kaputt gehen hier ist schon
ganz klar die rede auch von
suizidgedanken bei selbstständigen hier
ist die rede von tiefen depressionen bei
jugendlichen und entschuldigung dass das
dass das kann ich nicht akzeptieren
herr ramsauer jetzt sagt aber auch herr
tschentscher das doch am ende das virus
mehr oder weniger die spielregeln macht
das heißt wenn das eben jetzt mutiert
dann muss die regierung jahr darauf
reagieren am ende gibt ja dass wir uns
diesen ton vor was sagen sie darauf ja
erstmal guten abend aus dem chiemgau und
berchtesgadener land ich kann im grunde
genommen aus meiner erfahrung in meinem
wahlkreis also auf basis der partei und
auch der gesamten gesellschaft und
praktischen wirtschaft heraus aber auch
weit darüber hinaus nur das bestätigen
was in allen beiträgen jetzt sind dieser
sendung vorher gesagt worden ist als
erfahrung und gerade das was die
kollegen gesagt das was die kollegin
ihrer schimke gerade geschildert hat
aber diese sichtweise die dürfen wir
politiker natürlich so nicht stehen
lassen das den ton das virus an geben
wir sozusagen nur reagieren können
wir können schon attiyah und wir müssen
das in einer weise tun dass die
öffentlichkeit die bürgerinnen und
bürger das auch verstehen dass es
mehrmals gesagt worden jetzt schon in
den letzten beiträgen
man kann vieles nicht mehr erklären ich
kann es auch noch vieles nicht mehr
erklären dass der facheinzelhandel
vollkommen geschlossen bleibt und im
lebensmitteleinzelhandel bei den großen
discounter irgendwie nicht
lebensmittelprodukte im großen stil
verkauft werden
das baumschulen offen erzählt sozusagen
nicht zulassen dürfen und ähnliche dinge
also wir können das heft des handelns
durchaus im handel
ich glaube dass die regierung nach
solche runden wie wir sie am mittwoch
wieder erlebt haben sich zu sehr
defensiv verhalten und vor allen dingen
eins nicht geben nämlich eine
vernünftige perspektive wie es
weitergeht wir auch in den wahlkreisen
dann nutzen und den menschen als halt
geben können
herr ramsauer das ist der punkt der
viele menschen im moment beschäftigt die
sagen mensch wir brauchen irgendwie
zumindest die perspektiven weg raus zu
haben eine gewisse hoffnung muss man uns
doch irgendwie eröffnen und das ist
etwas was heute ein weiterer bayer zum
ausdruck gebracht hat nämlich der
trainer des fc bayern haben sie flick
ich finde so langsam kann man die
sogenannten experten gar nimmer gar
nicht mehr hören ja auch herr lauda bach
ja immer zu irgendetwas was zu sagen ja
immer ein thema wo es sich dann immer
wieder meldet ich finde die sogenannten
experten die politik soll zusammensetzen
und und wirklich mal eine strategie
entwickeln dass man auch mal irgendwann
wieder licht im tunnel sieht das ist
aktuell zu wenig finde ich gerade für
die bevölkerung für die bürger denn die
nicht in der situation sind wie wir
fußballer oder oder diese sportler
allgemein finde das sollte man mal
irgendwann miteinander finden an
miteinander finden um möglichst auch den
menschen in deutschland oder vielleicht
auch dann auf der ganzen welt wieder
dann übertragen ja wirklich mal zum
bisschen zuversicht für die zukunft
einfach aufgeben das ist aktuell nicht
davon hat schenker den menschen wieder
zuversicht geben dass es das was hansi
flick sich wünscht der trainer des fc
bayern die menschen wieder hoffnung
zuversicht geben hat er die korona
situation die lockdown situation im land
besser verstanden als sie oder karl
lauterbach kann ich glaube wir verstehen
schon diesen frust und auch diese
enttäuschung das ist jetzt nicht so
voran kommt wie wir uns das gewünscht
haben
ich finde mich ein bisschen dass herr
ramsauer dass ich mit herrn söder
besprochen hat was wir derzeit eben noch
nicht in einer sicheren lage sind und
dass sich das nicht die
ministerpräsidenten oder die
bundeskanzlerin überlegt hat dass wir
jetzt aus vorsicht vor diesen
möglicherweise infektiösen viren noch
mal ein stück vorsichtiger sein müssen
mit unseren maßnahmen
es geht ja darum dass diese ganzen
belastungssituationen unter den wir ja
alle leiden also wenn ich an die
familien denke wo die kinder jetzt seit
monaten nicht richtig zur schule gehen
konnten
das wird aber alles noch sehr viel
härter und schwerer wenn wir jetzt zu
früh in die lockerungen gehen und eine
dritte welle kommt ich erinnere mich
dass ich im oktober hier im studio
gesessen habe und habe gesagt wir sind
leider in einer sehr ernsten lage wir
müssen diese welle vermeiden die ich da
kommen sehen und da haben auch sehr
viele gesagt nein jetzt wieder in diese
maßnahmen einzusteigen und im lachen
dann haben wir festgestellt dass hat uns
die sache nicht erleichtert
es ist in dieser lage ein ausdruck der
ehrlichkeit dass wir sagen wir können
keinen verlässlichen planen und kein
termin sagen
deswegen wurde verlangt dann sag doch
mal was ist euer ziel wo müssen wir denn
sein damit wir stabil sind und da wurde
dann im prinzip gesagt gut die 50 ist
eine zahl die wir aus heutiger sicht
nicht mehr als als zuverlässig wirkt
hilflos bei vielen menschen wenn man
immer nur den locker und verliert zum
beispiel darauf diese perspektive länger
dauert herr ramsauer
das werden die termine setzen und dass
wir sagen das dauert jetzt wieder drei
vier wochen nicht aber auch an einer
rechtslage da kann ja kubicki als
bundestagsabgeordneter was zu sagen dass
das parlament erwartet der ausweg es
fehlt den menschen die hoffnung dass ich
das halt die würfel in diesem maß gerade
ich auf unendlich stellen und sagen wir
melden uns wenn es zu ende ist sondern
wir müssen unsere regeln begrenzen auf
höchstens vier wochen müssen uns immer
wieder neu beraten auch immer wieder
neue argumente nennen wir können auch
vor gericht nicht sagen wir haben uns
das irgendwann überlegt man seitdem
bleibt es dabei sondern wir müssen schon
auf sicht fahren wie man ja sagt weil
sich die lage eben im voraus nicht
vorherbestimmt sei sie wie er in change
sagt nur einmal mit der insel darüber
sprechen müssen und dann hätten sie
kapiert da ist es gar keine perspektive
gar nicht so eine hoffnung im moment
geben könnte soll ich verstehe diese
intervention des kollegen tschentscher
jetzt ganz natürlich sprechen wir auch
innerhalb der csu nun zu den
parlamentarischen gremien ständig mit
der london &
ministerpräsident markus söder perry
wirklich der letzte der nicht bescheid
weiß darüber was dann doch was ist los
ist und ich habe täglich jede menge
papier von den ortsvorsitzenden von der
basis meiner partei aber auch aus der
wirtschaft aus meinem wahlkreis
rückmeldungen zum teil seiner zweifel
gelassen über existenzängste das was ich
die basis jetzt wirklich wünscht
und das war natürlich dieser übergang
von 50 aufführungen von 30 ein richtiger
hammer eine halbe kein mittel schlag in
all diesen aufholen wenn sie mir
gelegenheit geben ich könnte gerne jede
menge zitieren was in 50 yards versetzen
in meinem wahlkreis oder geschäftsleute
banker familienväter familienmütter
eltern mit homeschooling erfahrene
ältere menschen ihre erfahrungen mit
news schreiben geben washington wir
sehen das im osten das sagen die
umfragen vor allen dingen brandenburg
also dort wo sie leben aber auch in
thüringen und dann auch ganz ganz stark
in sachsen die unterstützung für den
lock down kurs schwindet ja der frust
umso größer ist warum dort warum in
ihrer heimat so ganz besonders ach ich
bin mir gar nicht so sicher ob das
vorrangig in meiner heimat so ist ich
nur so ist ich denke es so es denn ganz
deutschland inzwischen so aber die
menschen tragen hier natürlich das herz
auf der zunge und sie sagen ganz klar
was ihm auf dem herzen liegt und ich bin
natürlich auch eine politikerin die sich
das auch anhört also ich muss niemanden
die welt erklären im gegenteil ich halte
meine klappe ich höre zu und ich nehme
das was ich dort erfahre auch mit in die
bundestagsfraktionen was mich im übrigen
unglaublich ärgert ist wir wissen alle
dass das leben mehr ist als die angst
vor einem videos und was von anfang an
nicht stattgefunden hat es einmal
darüber nachzudenken wie ist denn
eigentlich das virus geschehen in der
wirtschaft welche gefahr geht vom handel
aus welche gefahr geht von der
gastronomie aus diese fragen sind ja
eigentlich auch beantwortet wir kennen
die zahlen wir wissen dass es nicht
nennenswert ist und trotzdem muss
geschlossen werden und das versteht hier
keiner
und das führt zu einem massiven
vertrauensverlust in politische
entscheidungen
ich kann alle selbst auch die sehr
kontroversen diskussionen in den
sozialen netzwerken in der wissenschaft
unterhalb der innerhalb der virologen
schafft und natürlich wird auch das
diskutiert und man fragt sich warum
machen die das alles so was ist ja sinn
dahinter wir können keinen sinn erkennen
und das muss man doch mal sagen herr
palmer ich möchte auch einmal kurz auf
das zu sprechen kommen was hansi flick
heute zum ausdruck gebracht haben und
was ganz ganz viele jeden tag zum
ausdruck bringen nämlich dass diese
hoffnung fehlt und wir haben darüber
diskutiert geht das überhaupt also
könnte erhält tschentscher heute abend
hier sitzen und hoffnung machen fällt
ihm etwas ein
ein ausweg wie man den skizzieren könnte
obwohl die virus lage eben ja total
volatil und unsicher ist leicht denke
schon
also erstmal muss man festhalten wir
wissen zwar nicht so genau wie es mit
dieser neuen mutation ist aber in
großbritannien sinken die zahlen
schneller als bei uns also auch diese
mutation ist beherrschbar ist ja schon
mal hoffnung 1 wir sind dem nicht völlig
hilflos ausgeliefert
hoffnung 2 ist wir haben ja auch gelernt
wie man übertragungen verhindern kann
zum beispiel indem man den schnelltest
macht bevor man jemanden trifft wir
müssen weg von dieser strategie eben
menschlichen kontakt zu unterbinden
wir müssen nur die kontakte unterbinden
zwischen infizierten und anderen und
immer noch ist es so mehr als 99 prozent
der menschen sind ja nicht infiziert zum
aktuellen zeitpunkt deutlich weniger als
1 prozent sind infiziert also müssen wir
die tiere finden dafür müssen wir testen
und heute können sie vor fünf euro einen
selbsttest kaufen ich habe gerade wieder
24.000 stück bestellt wir machen das so
dass sie wegen alle erzieherin alle
schulden kind betreuerinnen auch die
lehrer und die abschlussklassen die
präsenzunterricht haben dürfen dass die
das angebot bekommen
dreimal die woche die schnelltests zu
machen worauf ich hinaus will ist wenn
wir handel bildung erziehung mit tests
sicher machen dann können wir auch
öffnen
wir sollten nicht mehr diese schwarz
weiß debatte auf oder zu führungs oder
der sollten mit hygiene konzept mit die
tests versorgen dass wir wieder bildung
betreuung handel und wirtschaft in
verantwortlicher weise betreiben können
herzens sowie man hat den eindruck herr
palmer versucht alles
um das heft des handelns in der hand zu
halten um ja selbst zu zeigen dass die
politik hier gestalten kann und nicht
nur zu sperren kann
warum machen sie ist nicht genau wie er
oder ist das quatsch wasser palma ist
eine sehr riskante strategie ist ich
sage noch einmal in richtung herrn
ramsauer war die bayerische
staatsregierung unterstützt den
beschluss denen die ministerpräsidenten
gemeinsam beschlossen haben und zwar
nicht weil sie nicht wüssten wie die
lage ist auch wie in hamburg haben
natürlich eine ganz schlimme situation
gerade im einzelhandel ich habe mich mit
sehr vielen menschen unterhalten die das
auch ganz ganz drastisch schildern in
welcher lage sie sind wo die rechnung
jeden tag ein laufen und sie nicht
wissen wann sie wieder öffnen können
das ist ja nicht der punkt das problem
ist dass wenn wir jetzt uns darauf
verlassen dass es schon gut gehen wird
dass es dann sehr schief gehen kann aber
ich glaube es war einmal ich habe
manchmal glaube ich verlässt sich gerade
nicht darauf das ist schon gut gehen
wird sondern er versucht ganz zu
gestalten richtig schnell deswegen ist
es eine strategie aufgesetzt auch
richtig und deswegen ist es gut dass wir
jetzt hoffentlich bald auch selbsttests
einsetzen können zum beispiel in schulen
und kitas und wir werden jeden
lockerungsschritte natürlich auch
verbinden mit einem verstärkten der
testeinsatz von schnelltests und dennoch
wenn sie sich die zahlen des aks ansehen
wir sind mit dem sogenannten r faktor
der uns zeigt wie stark derzeit noch die
virusaktivität ist mal eben so knapp
unter 1 wir sind bei 0,9
das heißt wir haben gar nicht viel zeit
um uns noch eine verschlechterte lage
sozusagen leisten zu können
und ich kann mir und mag mir nicht
vorstellen wie die stimmung noch einmal
schlechter wird wenn plötzlich die
inzidenz zahlen wieder nach oben wandern
denn die stimmung nochmals schlechter
wird dann ball nämlich noch mal auf herr
chen chow herr kubicki wenn die stimmung
nochmals schlechter wird wir haben in
den niederlanden sogar krawalle locker
und krawalle gesehen das war zwar eine
ganz seltsame mischung von menschen die
da auf der straße war auch viele
hooligans die diese stimmung ausgenutzt
haben und trotzdem war der ausgangspunkt
eben diese depression im zuge des lok
downs wir sehen im moment noch geht
umfragen zufolge
das breite unterstützung für die lok
down maßnahmen eine mehrheit kann man
sich da in sicherheit wiegen oder muss
man sagen mensch 30 über 30 prozent
bundesweit mittlerweile tief frustriert
sind und zunehmend wütend sind darüber
wie die entscheidungen getroffen werden
und was für entscheidungen getroffen
werden dass das ja gefährlich wird die
gefahr sehe ich auch weil mittlerweile
detail diskussionen die wir haben
wirklich gut umschlägt nachdem herr
lauterbach der kretschmann erklärt haben
ostern werde es keinen urlaub geben ich
komme ich aus steht deutschland als
urlaubsland sie müssen sich mal
anschauen wie die hoteliers und die
gastronomie hier darauf reagieren und
zwar deshalb weil sie sagen wir uns ist
erklärt wollen jetzt vielleicht 35 sind
mittelmaß oder das später vielleicht
dann soll wieder geöffnet werden jetzt
wird uns aber gleichzeitig gesagt in
ostern ist erst sechs wochen später als
im märz
er wird auch alles wieder zu sein wird
es keine reisen geben es gibt gar keine
perspektive und diese wut die
manifestiert sich um die wird irgendwann
umschlagen auch in gewalttätigkeiten das
befürchte ich auch vor allen dingen sie
muss darauf hinweisen und
ministerpräsident eines landes das
infektionsschutzgesetz hat die inzidenz
zahl 35 und 50 bewusst genannt beide
zahlen bewusst dem lande zwar deshalb
weil das eskalationsstufe sind von denen
ab sie grundrechts beschränkende
maßnahmen ergreifen ab 35 milde
maßnahmen ab 50 sehr schwere maßnahmen
im umkehrschluss unterschreiten sie die
50 sind maßnahmen nicht mehr
verhältnismäßig wenn sie bei 35 noch
anwenden wollen sie müssen also darauf
reagieren die rechtsprechung wird ihnen
das um die ohren hauen
vor allem mit der argumentation die sie
gewählt haben kommen wir aus dem locker
und nie wieder raus weil wir auch bei 35
nicht wissen ob die nächste mutation die
vielleicht auch wieder ihr fell die
infektiöse ist la palma hat recht wir
wissen momentan dass die britische
mutation keine schwereren verläufen und
ich mehr todesfälle verursacht als die
anderen und wenn es uns gelingt in den
alten und pflegeheim endlich der
versorgung zu tragen dass sie niemand
infiziert entweder durch tests durch
impfungen wenn wir die über 80 jährigen
schützen dann kann es die institute
sagen ich relativ egal sein weil wir
genau wissen dass bei den unter
50-jährigen hier kaum schwerer verläufe
seien auch immer welche aber äußerst
wenig dass wir damit vernünftig umgehen
können insofern denken sie noch mal
drüber nach daher günther abseits zu
recht gesagt wir werden einen stufenplan
aufbauen müssen weil wir nicht an
zu lassen können wir weit über 30 sind
ja genau deshalb herr kubicki ist ja
auch nicht nichts entschieden worden wir
haben jetzt entschieden dass wir erste
schritte machen der lockerung vor allem
bei den grundschulen und in der kita
betreuung und wir haben entschieden dass
etwas was nicht milch aber die meisten
menschen dann doch berührt und ich dass
es am ersten märz wieder möglich sein
soll
die friseure zu öffnen natürlich mit
hygiene konzepten und allen
vorsichtsmaßnahmen die die möglich sind
das heißt es ist ja nicht entschieden
worden wir machen jetzt nicht sondern
wir haben einfach gesagt für diese stufe
zwischen 50 und 35 dürfen wir jetzt
nicht unvorsichtig sein weil wir eben
sehr schnell hinterher nicht mehr über
35 oder 50 sprechen sondern weil wir
eben sehr schnell wieder richtung 100
gehen können und wir haben in
deutschland erlebt im november im
dezember wie schnell wir nicht nur bei
110 sondern bei 200 und wer mittlerweile
65 1000 tote in deutschland und ich kann
nur allen empfehlen einmal mit jemandem
zu sprechen der auf einer
intensivstation arbeitet oder der
einfach beschreiben kann
wie das wie die wie das
gesundheitssystem unter volllast ja ich
nehme an dass das wieder jeder von den
vieren gemacht hat dass das selbst
hauptmann hat das la palma sowieso getan
hat schimko und herr ramsauer frauchen
bringt wenig wenn wir gegen einbeck
entgegen da auch dies hat jetzt zusammen
gesessen bei einer talkshow auch die sec
wirft hindern können mit ausreichend
sp/2 s mit ausreichend testungen bei den
alten und pflegeheim wir hätten vieles
von dem verhindern können was deshalb
nicht geschehen ist weil die mittel
nicht da waren für die nach dem
infektionsschutzgesetz der bundesländer
zuständig gewesen wäre
froschschenkel nationale
kraftanstrengung jesus von der anfang an
ein wort dass vor allen dingen die
kanzlerin immer wieder benutzt hat sehen
sie das denn irgendwo dass es diese
nationale kraftanstrengung bis zuletzt
wirklich gegeben hat beim impfen bei
hygiene konzepten für gastronomie bei
der schule vor allen dingen bei der
digitalisierung und dem versuch so lange
wie möglich und so viel wie möglich
unterricht zu machen
naja also die nationale kraftanstrengung
sehe ich vor allen dingen
einschränkungen der freiheitsrechte so
und was an den schulen läuft ist ein
absolutes desaster
wir nennen uns bildungsrepublik ja wir
glauben wir sind die besten in dieser
welt und was wir im moment erleben ist
wirklich auch ein behörden versagen mit
blick auf die bildung unserer jüngsten
und das tut mir muss ich sagen
mindestens genauso wie noch nie
das scheitern der wirtschaftlichen
existenz vieler menschen in diesem land
wie lange glauben sie herr palmer werden
sie ihren geschäftsinhabern in tübingen
noch erklären müssen dass die dicht
machen dicht halten dich bleiben müssen
darauf habe ich wenig einfluss ich will
es ihnen auch nicht erklären wir haben
der incident zeit zwei wochen von unter
35 deswegen bin ich der meinung dass die
aufmachen sollten natürlich mit guten
konzepten zum beispiel terminvergabe
immer nur ein kunde wird es ein kleiner
laden ist nach dem anderen da kann man
sogar zwischendurch lüften
bei den größeren kaufhäusern testangebot
am einlass da kann man ja sehr sehr viel
machen vorher war ja auch schon relativ
wenig infektionen in den geschäften und
genug hantschel antworten natürlich dass
sie sagen
der grund warum der nicht öffnen sollen
ist das sei zu riskant
ich sage ihnen umgekehrt was sie machen
ist zu gefährlich und zwar sicher
gefährlich das eine ist unsicher da
wissen nicht was die mutation mit uns
gemacht vielleicht gibt es eine dritte
welle
es kann aber auch sein wie letztes jahr
die die erste welle ist ausgeübt im
frühjahr nicht wegen der maßnahmen
sondern gegen sommer könnte auch mit der
zweiten welle passieren und wenn die
kinder und jugendpsychiatrie in tübingen
gehe dann warten darunter drei kinder
wir bekommen keine behandlung keinen
platz stationär obwohl sie das müssten
da sind so viele krankheiten jetzt bei
den kindern die da durchbrechen die
schlimmer werden die immer häufiger
werden die eindeutig lockt dann folgen
sind und ich finde sie müssen sich schon
auch die frage stellen ob sie das alles
so ohne mit der schulter zucken
hinnehmen können ob das nicht auch
risiken sind die mit betrachtet werden
müssen und ob in dieser abwägung nicht
mehr für hygiene konzepte für öffnung
der kitas schulen und handeln macht
ihnen das angst stiert als halb voll an
es gibt aber die das 1
es war wie man vorher wissen auf die
leichte schulter und ich darf ihr
ministerpräsident in baden württemberg
hat das auch mit völlig klar aber mal
ganz kurz
das ist ja der reigen riesigen rolle
dass ich sozusagen herrn palmer als
vertreter der grünen einer
regierungsmaschine möglich ist völlig
okay ich mache das gerne nur das ist ja
unsere überzeugung dass hier niemand
etwas auf die leichte schulter nimmt ich
darf daran erinnern dass herr
kretschmann richtig fest entschlossen
war die kitas und die grundschulen zu
eröffnen sie haben aus überzeugung ist
aber auch dass man sich in einer kita
einen ausbruch mit einer britischen
mutation hatte und dann nimmt man die
dinge dann nicht mehr auf der leichten
schuld auf die leichte schulter wurde
das abgesetzt und es wurde was ich
richtig finde überlegt müssen wenn ich
doch noch mal schauen wie sich diese
mutation praktisch auswirkt ich glaube
auch dass wir bekommen auch sehr bald
und noch mal hoffnung zu geben
wir bekommen glaube ich sehr bald einen
guten eindruck davon wie schnell sich
die mutation ausbreiten und wenn wir
dann sehen und das ist ihm hoffentlich
anfang märz dann schon der fall dass wir
damit zurechtkommen dann bin ich der
letzte der sagt also nur wollen wir die
lockerungen noch zurückhaltend ich bin
aber die ich sie die hamburger zahlen
ich bin momentan nicht so sehr
optimistisch weil ich eher das gefühl
habe wir bewegen uns hier auf einem
plateau zu und müssen uns wirklich
sorgen machen dass wir eben zunächst
einmal eine dritte welle vermeiden
solange es noch sehr kalt ist und wie
mit den impfungen aus den gründen die
wir alle kritisieren noch nicht so
schnell vorangekommen also das ganze
geschieht aus angst dass uns eben diese
dritte welle trifft würde sagen es ist
eine kurze recherche der eine
verantwortung tragen für viele tote die
wir die wir vermeiden können und
deswegen die frage können sie das
verantworten weil das ist ja die zweite
angst die kommt wir erleben erhebliche
schäden bei den kindern wir erleben
erhebliche schäden an der wirtschaft und
die frage haben sie angst davor dass
einmal verantworten zu müssen und es gar
nicht verantworten zu können wenn es all
die läden die jetzt wieder aufmachen
soll möglicherweise darüber gibt wer
antworten ja auf unterschiedliche weise
auf diese gefahren also wir haben ja
eine notbetreuung für kita kinder die
sehr sehr die nicht nur gering ist also
wir sind derzeit bei 30 bis 35 prozent
der kinder die schon betreut werden in
der kita weil die familiären bedingungen
oder die sozialen bedingungen so sind
dass es nicht zu hause geht
wir haben auch eine eine notbetreuung in
schulen die umso umfangreicher ist je
jünger die kinder sind das heißt niemand
nimmt irgendwas auf die leichte schulter
und wir versuchen wirklich in dieser
pandemie das zu tun was das was
irgendwie die diese schäden die die
erstellten können vermeiden
die frage ist sie los angeles jetzt ein
bisschen ist für an den
wahlkreisabgeordneten für alle
bundestagsabgeordneten für diejenigen
die in den parteien mit ihren
landesregierungen ja gemeinsam sprechen
jetzt wirklich die botschaft dass wir
ein stück weit gemeinsam erklären und
nicht den einen die beschlüsse über
lassen und dann allen anderen nur den
frust aufnehmen
die hätten die bestellten gerne anders
getroffen aber er scheint noch einmal
aufgaben lang muss manchmal lagen
gedeihen sagen was wann gelockert werden
genau das hat herr palmer in teilen
sogar gemacht hat ja einmal den gedanken
aufnehmen was ist wenn aldi lesen die
bei denen wir fragen wann machen die
endlich wieder auf gar nicht mehr
aufmachen können weil sie möglicherweise
für immer zu sind wir haben unsere
zuschauer gefragt wie es bei ihnen
eigentlich in den wahlkreisen vor der
haustür aussieht in den innenstädten
dafür eine dampfwalze über unseren
einzelhandel einsatz der durch mark und
bein geht von ihm carsten linnemann cdu
mittelstandschef es ist eine letzte
warnung vom großen sterben unserer
innenstädte in der korona krise
und so erleben sie unsere zuschauer dass
sterbende innenstädte schon jetzt
und das sind die harten zahlen die
parfümeriekette douglas macht
deutschlandweit 60 filialen dicht etwa
jeden achten laden die friseurkette
klier insolvent die deko kette depot
schließt 35 filialen das steakhaus
maredo insolvent ebenso esprit runners
point sarah schließt weltweit 1200 läden
und auch h&m und sein filialnetz massiv
aus wie man hier sehen kann hinter mir
alles leer
unsere gemeinde in reppenstedt landkreis
lüneburg
wir haben zwar nicht viel aber einiges
was leider geschlossen hat oder
schließen muss wie hier zum beispiel ein
baby massage rückbildungskurs kind ein
kleiner dönerladen nagelstudio ja ich
stehe vor dem schuhgeschäft inspektor
ist schon seit 130 jahren existiert und
die kostet wochen bildet das möchte auch
gar nicht selber was dazu sagen
und so wird es wahrscheinlich vielen
gehen und hier in kiel oder
wahrscheinlich auch wenn man die sich
nicht mehr untereinander helfen würde
die katastrophe noch schlimm das
einzigste was überleben wird es mit
traurigkeit zu sagen ist leider das
gestattet bestattungsinstitut links um
die ecke
die haben denke ich mal einiges zu tun
herr kubicki das bestattungsinstitut hat
gut zu tun ansonsten dönerläden sind
dicht handy läden sind dicht
einzelhandel ist dicht ja das ist so
weil sie ja auch nicht öffnen dürfen
palm hat ja zu recht schon darauf
hingewiesen dass wir schon beim ersten
lok darunter festgestellt habe danach
verstehen konnten
das jedenfalls aus den einzelnen mit den
hygiene schutz konzepten die umgesetzt
worden waren infektionsketten nicht zu
nachzuvollziehen sind es war nicht
entstanden sind ich sehe das bei mir
selbst wenn sie bei mir als kilometer
weiter fahren dann haben sie eine
innenstadt in der eine ganze reihe von
leben bereits zu hören wo sie einen
schock ein star wie das gerade gesehene
wohl nichts mehr drin ist wo auch dann
teilweise steht wenn wir mit den
deutschen käufer dürfen machen wir den
schlussverkauf hier hört auf und ich bin
sicher dass in die innenstädte dann auch
niemanden
nein geht wir werden die irgendwann um
an den dörfern wohnquartiere weil wie
gesagt wenn die ketten rausgehen und die
ein zahlungsgeschäfte wie wichtig sie
für die versorgung vor ort wenn die
nicht mehr überleben können dann würde
es ganz hart tschentscher mailand hat
geöffnet und 60 prozent der anlagen ist
geschäft hatte nicht erneut geöffnet das
menetekel auch für uns man ist nicht
gerade bei den kleineren und mittleren
städten wo es auf den kundenkontakt
intensiver ankommt als in großen städten
weil sie dort mehr menschen haben ist
das eine mittlere katastrophe die sich
auch nicht wieder gut machen ist
bestimmt gemahlen wir hier den schwarzen
peter an die wand oder ist es wirklich
schon so dramatisch in den vor allen
dingen kleinstädten in den innenstädten
absolut absolut kann ich voll
unterstützen meine gewerbetreibenden
sagen mir dass es noch bis märz
durchhalten danach wird's schwierig und
wenn ich solche bilder sehe wie gerade
eben dargestellt durch die zuschauer
habe ich ein bisschen angst in die ddr
zeit zurückzuversetzen zurückversetzt zu
werden wo wir auch so eine lehrerin die
schaufenster hatten und ist nichts darf
wenn sie das übertriebene tschentscher
nein das ist tatsächlich ganz besonders
problematisch weil die weil die
innenstädte schon vor corona ja eine
sehr schwierige lage hatten durch den
online-handel waren jedenfalls in
hamburg der stationäre handel in den
teuren lagen da wo die mieten sehr sehr
hoch sind schon vorher unter druck und
das wird natürlich jetzt noch einmal
verschärft auch wir haben natürlich
jetzt schließung von traditionellen
großen kaufhäusern und müssen deswegen
konzepte haben die wir die innenstädte
wieder beleben
das ist ein thema was noch mal gesondert
von corona bei uns bearbeitet wird das
hätten wir im übrigen auch gemüse ohne
corona krise
denn diese entwicklung hin zum online
handel hat die die immer so will die die
bedingungen für den stationären handel
in den teuren lagen ja sowieso sehr sehr
starken erschwert herr ramsauer jetzt
wer möglicherweise ein bisschen mehr
ruhe an der einzelhandels front wenn die
hilfen alle so geflossen wären wie
vorher angekündigt na ja klar dass das
war eines der themen jetzt in den
letzten wochen das viel angekündigt
wurde und wenig geflossen ist das ist
jetzt mehrfach gesagt worden
aber das ist ja nur ein teil ein kleiner
faktor von der ganzen gesamten
frustration die in der bevölkerung
herrscht
ihr motto ist ja heute da spricht die
basis und wenn sie erlauben dann die
sich mit kurz vor was aus dem bereich
meiner 50 platz vorsitzenden mit meinem
wahlkreis heute wieder ziemlich kommen
jetzt oben da steht stellvertretend für
jede menge post die jeden tag bekomme
schreibt mir ortsvorsitzende lieber
peter rückmeldung aus dem volk aktuell
wird es als nicht mehr nachvollziehbar
sondern als glück empfunden die
anforderungen für lockerung immer wieder
nach unten zu verschieben wer einem esel
dem immer leckere karotte an einer angel
vor der nase helle realistisches festes
ziel erfolgsmeldung einhaltung von
zusagen das brauchen wir jetzt und dann
lange geht es sonst nicht mehr gut und
der zivile ungehorsam oder schlimmeres
viele grüße und so weiter und so fort
dass die jetzt fortsetzen
einmal stundenlang darin kommt zum
ausdruck die frustriert die
öffentlichkeit ist und wie klar wir
jetzt brauchen das um auf ihre frage
zurückzukommen
die zahlungen endlich schließen müssen
ich glaube meinem freund und unseren
wirtschaftsminister peter altmaier alles
getan hat um die dinge zum laufen zu
bringen und ich muss mal ein das zur
entschuldigung sagen warum gelernt man
nicht in der politik irgendwo sondern
gekommen und man muss sich irgendwie
bewältigen
und wir müssen jetzt alles dafür tun
dass die die zahlungen laufen geholfen
wird aber auch bei anderen zeichnen
natürlich auch schnellstens wieder
öffnen mit besten konzepten
der hygiene und alles der einzelhandel
von dem die rede war der kann das ja tun
er ist dazu in der lage auch große teile
der gastronomie hotellerie nehmen sie
meinen wahlkreis zwischen chiemsee und
heran sauer ich will ganz kurz ein paar
zahlen sich für ganz ganz kurz ein
herzlicher weil sie klug reden lassen
durften sie durften sogar eindrucksvoll
vorlesen von der basis bei sich von der
csu basis wollte überhaupt mitzumachen
bei ihnen das nehmen wir auf dank herr
ramsauer eine stimmung dort aus bayern
aus dem chiemgau ich möchte einmal ganz
kurz mit herrn kubicki noch mal über die
person von herrn altmaier sprechen denn
herr ramsauer sagt jetzt mensch der
hatte alles getan wirklich dass die
helfen fließen aber wirtschaftsminister
der es nicht schafft die november helfen
bis mitte februar aus zahlbar zu machen
ist der richtige im amt zunächst galt
natürlich persönlicher ramsauer nicht
alles machen das ist klar aber es ist
sein verantwortungsbereich und wer sich
anschaut dass ihnen nicht mal die
november eben auch nicht ausgezahlt
worden sind dass er noch nicht mal mit
der überbrückungshilfe 2 fertig sind das
überbrückungshilfe drei die ab 15
dezember gelten sollte frühestens ende
märz ausgezahlt wird da muss ich schon
sagen in dem verantwortungsbereich von
herrn altmaier ist vieles schiefgegangen
es geht nach wie vor weiter tief und
wenn man dann von verantwortung spricht
dann sollte man sich im zweifel auch
trage ich akzeptiere auch nicht mehr
dass immer wieder gesagt wird du uns
leid wir haben da fehler gemacht hätten
wäre das besser machen sollen
ein bisschen professionell an die sache
herangehen wie man subventionen ausgehe
das kann man von einem
wirtschaftsminister schweiz verlangen
also kann sich deutschland den noch
leisten herr kubicki und nicht wie
bisher haben wir uns in geleistet
bedauerlicherweise mit fatalen
konsequenzen wird wieder menschen aus
der wirtschaft es wäre gut werden einen
schnelleren menschen in dieser
verantwortung
das ist das personelle herr palmer jetzt
lassen sie uns noch mal über die
einzelhändler sprechen eben eine
eindruck war das haben wir gerade in den
zuschauer stimmen auch gehört die kam
eben aus coburg die kam aus kevelaer
die kam nicht aus hamburg aus münchen
aus berlin wo mittlerweise dann nicht
zuerst die
und m filiale schließen oder die douglas
filiale und so weiter und so fort wird
es also eine weitere kraft verschiebung
geben von den kleinstädten in richtung
der großstädte wo es daneben noch alles
gibt aber ja in den etwas ländlicheren
regionen nicht mehr glaubt nicht dass es
den großstädten besser geht es trifft
alle in die verzweiflung die ich da von
den händlern hörer die ist wirklich mag
und beiden erschütternd das sind
schicksale das in existenzen das sind
lebenswerke die zerstört werden die
menschen sehen nicht mehr wie sie da
raus kommen sollen wird auf die
altersversorgung jetzt geopfert
ich weiß von mehreren die nicht mehr
aufmachen werden wir sind wirklich
schlimme zustände
und es ist ja einfach nicht so dass das
sicher ist oder auch nur wahrscheinlich
dass corona die dritte welle produziert
wenn die aufmachen dürfen deswegen
verstehen sie es auch nicht warum sollte
es denn besser sein wenn die leute in
großer zahl bei aldi an der schlange
stehen sich auf den füßen trainer dort
das kaufen was die auch im sortiment
haben nur ein besserer qualität aber
geschlossen bleiben müssen das kann man
nicht erklären ich wünsche ihnen auch
nicht mehr weil ist auch unter pandemie
gesichtspunkten einfach nicht logisch
ist mit guten hygiene konzepten können
die aufnahmen und einsatz noch da geht
es nicht um mehr als um mammon
die kommunen sind die keimzelle der
demokratie hier entsteht bürger sind und
bürgerstolz wenn dieser ort der sozialen
interaktion verödet wenn er stirbt das
hat gründe warum das in der deutschen
sprache sterben heißt dass innenstädte
sterben können dann ist es langfristig
für unsere demokratie für die
freiheitliche verfassung der
gesellschaft für alles was uns lieb und
teuer ist ein immenser schaden und nur
gesellschaften die frei und demokratisch
sind können sich auch dauerhaft
gesundheit leisten und aufbauen das ist
nicht einfach nur leben und tod in
corona infektionen auf der anderen seite
und alles andere ist schnöder mammon
diese rechnung geht nicht auf und
deswegen müssen wir halt tschentscher
auch an dieser seite vorsichtig sein es
darf nicht noch vorsicht gegen dem virus
geben
das muss auch vorsicht vor fundamentalen
zerstörung in unserer gesellschaft
falten und die vermisse ich bei ihnen
also sie zerstören sagte palmer
übersetzt von mir
gerade den marktplatz der auf dem die
demokratie entstanden ist der marktplatz
geht uns verloren ja das ist ein
schwerer vorwurf den herr palmer hier
erhebt die nicht aber nicht annehme
wir haben im laden im einzelhandel ja
die situation erlebt im november wir
haben den einzelhandel nicht geschlossen
gerade aus den gründen die die jetzt
eine rolle spielen wir haben bis mitte
dezember durchgehalten aber es ist doch
für alle erkennbar gewesen die
bayerischen instanzen sind auf über 200
gelaufen in baden-württemberg hatten der
schlimmste hohe incidents werte in
sachsen ist es in dieser phase massiv
nach oben gegangen und ist das natürlich
nicht nur der einzelhandel gewesen
aber selbstverständlich hat dann als wir
mitte dezember damit einen gegen
lockdown gegangen sind sind die
instanzen zurückgegangen und deswegen
hat es eben einfach eine eine auswirkung
je weniger kontakte ist es gibt umso
geringer sind die risiken aber ich will
gar nicht allen punkten die hier genannt
sind widersprechen natürlich wenn wir
schritte machen müssen wir darauf achten
dass wir sie dass wir sie begleiten
durch möglichst viel sicherheit durch
schnelltests und durch durch die gene
konzepte nur momentan ist eben die die
eine vereinbarung in deutschland dass
wir sagen es ist noch einen tick zu früh
dass wir solche großen schritte gehen
können
die ersten schritte mit den friseuren
mit der eröffnung von schulen vor allem
grundschulen und kitas sollen ja jetzt
schrittweise gegangen werden und sobald
wir sehen dass die instanz stabil bleibt
wird es natürlich im einzelhandel das
ist ja schon entschieden worden dass ist
auch ein stück weit kritik sogar dass es
heißt warum fand er direkt mit dem
einzelhandel ist das denn wichtiger als
die kultur und der sport es ist ja so
wenn sie an einer stelle einen schritt
gehen fragt sich doch gleich ganz
deutschland wir sind mit einem anderen
bereich der ja auch eine große bedeutung
hinten noch bei dem die gläubigen
einlagen ist sehr komplex und das ist
nicht nicht sachgerechte das ist nicht
angemessen so schwere irgend jemanden
der diese entscheidung mitträgt nicht
bewusst mit welchen belastungen das
einhergeht
herr ramsauer ein gedanke um das heft
des handelns wieder ja in die eigene
hand in die hand der politik zu geben
wäre das war es in schweden gerade
passiert nämlich
zusagen mit einem digitalen impfpass
beispielsweise da könnt ihr wieder
reisen das ist das was die schweden im
moment sagen wäre das eine möglichkeit
finden sie das gut wenn in bayern die
einzelhändler sagen würden ja also wer
geimpft ist der darf bei mir wieder in
den laden oder die gastwirte sagen wer
geimpft ist der darf wieder das pärchen
bei mir trinken
so ein quatsch das wäre genauso blöd
sein gewinnziel entscheiden würden das
nur gegen die bild -zeitung noch
bekommen und die anderen licht also das
ist jetzt sehr überspitzt aber eine
solche teilung bevölkerung können wir
nicht war unmöglich das schafft
unmöglich zusätzlich böses blut
sie sagen so zu sagen das sei
unsolidarisch das ist ja die
argumentationslinien die man ganz oft
hier aus der deutschen auswärtigen und
olli darin das hat mit solidarität aber
nicht der eigentlich sehr wenig zu tun
aber es nur beliebte journalistin frage
die sich hier aufgreifen
ich halte so eine zweiteilung der
bevölkerung einfach nicht durchsetzbar
und nicht machbar und ich glaube als
männer ganz praktischen erfahrung und
davon habe ich garantiert viel mehr ist
einzel holte beispielsweise oder die
gastronomie gastronomie mit sieg nicht
machtlos
das sagt peter ramsauer ich habe heute
nachmittag mit anderer stiegemann
gesprochen dem schwedischen digital
minister der dort eben diesen corona
impfpass den digitalen gerade 1 führt
und ihn gefragt ob er das nachvollziehen
kann dass viele sagen in deutschland ab
das ist doch ungerecht oder
möglicherweise sogar unsolidarisch und
dass seine antwort nein überhaupt nicht
ich glaube dass die impfung ein faktor
solidarität ist denn wenn man die
impfung hat dann schützt man die älteren
mann schützt die anfälligste personen
vor ansteckungen hier eine anforderungen
zu stellen dass man zum beispiel
negativen caubet test vorlegt es doch
nicht unsolidarisch da wird sich immer
stärker dann diese forderungen nach
impfungen durchsetzen
na wann sind sie fertig mit der
aufstellung dieses digitalen im passes
diesem sommer so hoffen wir am ersten
juni in der zukunft werden je mehr
menschen geimpft sein werden auch die
fluggesellschaften und die gesamte
reisebranche zunehmend das verlangen
ich glaube das wort kommen das wird sich
durchsetzen
auch bei vielen veranstaltern und
fluggesellschaften
herr kubicki irgendwann sagt eigentlich
die fluggesellschaften die machen das
doch sowieso am ende die werden sowieso
von sich aus diesen ja impfpass
sozusagen einführen
kommt das also so wir werden uns hier in
der politik dagegen wehren einen solchen
impfpass auch in deutschland einzuführen
und am ende machen wir unternehmer vor
allen dingen die große fluggesellschaft
sowieso machen was sie wollen der
private unternehmer die nicht der
grundversorgung dienen dürfen dass der
turm dem spaß ist ja auch nichts anderes
als die dauer eine dokumentation das
dann negativ ist also keinen anderen
anstecken kann dass die gefahren die von
einem ausstieg ähnliche panne gegeben
ich halte aber die diskussion über die
zweiteilung von die impfung nicht
geimpften er für eine schatten
diskussionen scheindiskussion weil je
mehr menschen geimpft sind desto
schneller sinken auch die inzidenz
zahlen je schneller gehen sie denn
zahlen sinken desto mehr muss auch
wieder von verfassungs wegen geöffnet
werden und insofern glaube ich dass eine
frage die uns vielleicht vier bis sechs
wochen beschäftigen würde wenn
institutionen deutschland sich deutlich
verbessern würde aber nicht dauerhaft
also noch einmal wenn man an ihm spaß
hat kann man nur dokumentieren ich muss
jetzt keinen schnelltest war weil ich
wie gesagt bereits gegen vor und bin und
deshalb nicht mehr andere anstecken kann
das ist die voraussetzung wäre also ein
dauerhaftes papier muss nicht jedes mal
zwei tage papier oder ein tage papier
vorlegen
schnell testen lassen aber noch einmal
je mehr und je schneller das passiert
desto weniger gibt es gibt es eine
distanz zwischen gegenstand nicht geben
eine schnelle schlussrunde beginn mit
frau schimke wir haben jetzt viel bei
den frust im land heute gehört und der
change hat sich ja einiges heute anhören
müssen danke dass sie es aber getan
haben und aus ihrer sicht geschildert
haben wie kommen wir frau schimke wie
kommen wir jetzt alle miteinander wieder
zusammen
so wie schaffen wir auf hoffnungs kurse
umzuschlagen
naja durch ganz klare signale seitens
der bundesregierung also das was hier
gerade dosis an der basis in der
bevölkerung vor ort muss endlich gehört
werden und man sollte sich endlich nicht
nur mit der frage auseinandersetzen wie
kriegen wir mehr impfstoff und die
schützen die risiko gefährdete personen
sondern vor allem auch wie bringen wir
die menschen wieder in lohn und brot
ramsauer selbe frage an sie oder wird's
dann einfach die bundestagswahl richten
müssen wir bis dahin müssen wir das
problem gelöst haben
aber mein wunsch ist ganz einfach das
dirigieren denn ich sage es wirklich im
wahrsten sinne des wortes die jenigen
die regierungsverantwortung tragen es
signale hören aus dem bereich der ihr
denn wenn das nicht hinreichend der fall
ist und zukunft muss das einfach gesehen
dann wird die kluft und das programm
noch viel viel mehr als jetzt noch vor
ließen das kann sich unser land umwelt
gar keinen umständen leisten japaner was
wäre jetzt ihre botschaft an alle
frustrierten im moment frustration
bringt eigentlich weiter also positiv in
die zukunft schauen wenn man das angebot
bekommt wahrnehmen und dafür sorgen dass
man selber genäht und anforderungen ein
held das ist die beste methode um aus
dieser pandemie rauszukommen also die
politik heißt es jetzt impfen und testen
was das zeug hält kubicki
bei der vorletzten epic hat weiß das hat
sich die bundesregierung für sich
verpflichtet ist der letzten entwickler
einen stufenplan da sagen dass wir tief
vorzulegen der genau sagt unter welchen
bedingungen was die der zur normalität
zurückgeführt werden kann das wirklich
noch einmal verschoben werden aber die
menschen haben ein recht darauf dass sie
wie einige länder das macht dann steht
sie heute stand niedersachsen thüringen
merkt man sie haben ein recht darauf zu
wissen oder welchen bedingungen
dann können sie mit welchen schritten
rechnen ohne dauer vertröstet zu werden
und ich kann ihnen eigentlich ja sagen
wir sitzen ja auch als fdp eine
regierung in schleswig holstein wenn es
mal in der nächsten pk am 7 märz eine
solche vorlage des bundes ist nicht
gehen wird der tschentscher nord
schleswig holstein seinen stufen plan
umsetzen sagte ich bin extra nochmal
gesagt die bundesregierung
hier in vorleistung und sie muss ihre
aufgabe erfüllen wenn nicht müsse das
ländern zweifel übernehmen wann kommt
der stufenplan oder machen sie dann mit
dem günter im zweifel gemeinsam die
sache von hamburg über schleswig
holstein haben wir müssen in hamburg
ohnehin gemeinsame sache machen mit
niedersachsen oder schleswig-holstein
wenn schleswig holstein und
niedersachsen eröffnungs schritte gehen
müssen wir sie fast gezwungenermaßen mit
gehen weil wir ja sonst der mobilität
auslösen weil die leute dann nach
niedersachsen oder schleswig-holstein
fahren würden zum einkaufen oder wann
kommt der bundesweite stufenklage ist
wird einen bundesweiten stufenplan geben
wir haben nur jetzt der zeit gesagt es
ist noch so viel unsicherheit in der
lage als dass man präzise einzelne
stufen jetzt festlegen
die unsicherheit bleibt immer das sei
nicht im frühjahr gesagt hatte lang im
plan kommt nie nein also der die
unsicherheit ist derzeit sehr groß weil
wir wissen wie schnell sich diese
mutationen verbreiten aber sie sind
momentan eben noch sehr gering in
deutschland wir haben bei der letzten
erhebung 5,8 also sechs unter 6%
britische mutation gehabt in deutschland
wir müssen jetzt sehen ob es so schnell
geht wie in wie in anderen ländern das
bei 30 40 prozent mutations anteil
stehen und was nicht was daraus werden
und in dem moment kann man belastbarer
sagen ob sie das infektionsgeschehen
trotzdem gut im griff haben und dann
kann man eben auch diese stufen
festlegen dass es jedenfalls so
vereinbart worden dass wir diesen stufen
plan aufstellen
aber man muss ehrlich sein stufen pläne
zu diskutieren die dann noch mehr
hoffnungen machen um das dann hinterher
wieder einzukassieren das ist eben auch
keine strategie und deswegen war es
jetzt ehrlich zu sagen wir müssen jetzt
noch mal bis anfang märz
diese diese situation beobachten
ich finde das richtig wir dürfen nicht
zu früh jetzt lockern wir fallen zurück
und erleben das was andere europäische
nachbarländer erleben immer diese stop
and go mit noch viel mehr todesfällen
und schlimme auswirkungen für die
wirtschaft aber nee sich entwerfen
planen nächste mpk ich ich gehe davon
aus dass wir in der nächsten mpk darüber
detaillierter reden können aber wir
haben hier sie haben die ihre gäste so
eingeladen dass csu cdu spd fdp und
grüne alle beteiligt sind alle regieren
ein stück weit in unterschiedlichen
landesregierungen mit hinunter kubicki
sie haben den stufenplan ich könnte ihn
sofort auf den tisch legen und ich
zwinge sie den umzusetzen wenn sie es
nicht bundesweit hinkriegen
aber das ist eben so viel vernunft ist
in den landesregierungen dass man eben
dann doch sich verständigt auf ein
gemeinsames vorgehen denn was
bürgerinnen und bürger überhaupt nicht
ertragen können ist dass plötzlich alle
irgendetwas machen was sie große kritik
in der vergangenheit dass es zu viel
regionale unterschiede gibt wir brauchen
schon an gemeinsamen plan und ich gehe
davon aus dass wir ihn aufstellen und
ihnen darüber dann entscheiden wenn wir
die sicherheit haben dass das auch
vertretbar ist
danke dass jeder heute abend hier bei
bild so sehr für seine überzeugung
kämpft hat danke an den ersten
bürgermeister von hamburg peter
tschentscher danke und wolfgang kubicki
jana schimke peter ramsauer und corus
palma und ihnen allen auch zu hause
einen schönen rest unter gehabt
[Musik]